morgen herr assmann seit gestern wissen
wir also die berliner charité hat
bestätigt dass sie gift gefunden haben
aus der wirkstoffgruppe der
cholinesterase hemmer was genau ist das
klingt harmloser waren ziemlich schlimm
es gilt muss man sagen
also was ist das viele kennen vielleicht
noch die 605 als pflanzenschutzmitteln
aus diesen gruppen sind auch kampfstoff
entwickelt worden
das heißt wenn wir uns das vorstellen
dass es nach und die nervenleitung geht
nicht geradeaus durch bis hin zur vom
kopf bis zum fuß sondern da sind immer
kleine lücken und diese lücken werden
von botenstoffen überwunden ja das ist
das fazit schulen so da aber dass auch
immer wieder regeneriert werden muss
wird es auch abgebaut abgebaut wird es
durch die acetylcholin erst bei hase das
ist ein enzym war es dass aktien china
baut weil sonst würde es zu einer
dauererregung am nerven und da genau
setzt der giftstoff an
das verhindert den abbau des ac turin
und das bedeutet das praktisch den nerv
dauer erregt wird
es findet keine koordination der stadt
und einen dauer erregung dessen er uns
nicht nur eines nach sondern die ganzen
namen oben
deswegen auch diese übelkeit deswegen
auch das erbrechen des patienten von der
wahl nie und so weiter und so weiter
nichtsdestotrotz darf man nicht
vergessen dass nicht nur der patient
gefährdet ist ja der dass bekommen hat
kann das über stoffe aufgenommen haben
wie zum beispiel getrunken haben kann es
aber auch die haut bekommen haben und
deswegen zeigen auch erklären ich war
auch weil die gestern abend noch in die
ambulanz gerufen worden ist man muss
natürlich auch überlegen ob sie nicht
unfreiwillig auch kontaminiert worden
ist mit dem gift nehmen sie ihren mann
berührt hat und so weiter
das sind hochgefährliche kontakt
gestellt der tod ist er qualvoll
und an sich muss man so sagen
unkalkulierbar auch für die umgebung
deswegen haben sie vielleicht auch im
fernsehen gesehen als er transportiert
wird
besser so hart wie im kokon war auch um
die anderen behandler angehörige zu
weiter zu schützen
du musst jetzt also unterschiedlich
behandelt werden
wir haben von der charité gehört das
momentan nicht mehr in akuter
lebensgefahr ist trotzdem aber noch im
koma die charité hat auch von spätfolgen
gesprochen was genau bedeutet das was
macht dieses gift mit einem wenn herr
navalny tatsächlich im koma aufwachen
würde womit es dann zu rechnen
damit schwer zu sagen hat er dann jahren
stehen insoweit beispiel dass die arten
eingeschränkt ist dann wie ist die
bewegungsmöglichkeiten sind die nerven
wieder regenerierbar hat er ist der
bewegungsablauf weltsprache gingen wir
wissen es einfach noch nicht weil diese
ganzen man muss leider sagen dass diese
eher kampfstoffe zum beispiel wie
verursacherin usw immer weiter
entwickelt worden sind zb tabu als er
ihn ist tausendmal wichtiger als e 605
und das gilt was in der sowjetunion bzw
wussler entwickelt worden nur wie schock
sind eine sind auch noch mal 10 bis 20
mal gefährlicher als dieses gift man
muss aber auch wissen wer hat setzt so
was ein ich meine putins bestimmt kein
dummer aber ist er wirklich so dumm dass
er das so offensichtlich macht wer hat
da die kontrolle in russland zurzeit das
sind alles fragen die jetzt so hochkommt
aber es ist wirklich sehr brutale
einsatz um menschen zu schädigen oder
auch umzubringen
vor allem muss man ja auch überlegen sie
müssen das ja schon in gewisser weise
dosieren
damit sie nicht umbringen und nur
schädigen ja was für eine botschaft
stecke dahinter und so weiter
es sind also eine ganze menge fragen und
das finde ich schon sehr erschüttert was
da läuft